and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're going to talk
about sustainability we're gonna talk
about overconsumption we're gonna talk
about some environmental concerns we're
gonna talk about health and beauty
products right I want to know have some
beer it's so amazing oh man I'm so glad
we have an expert here to help us talk
about all these things we're gonna we're
gonna talk about shopping with intention
and we're gonna answer your questions
with today's guest Amy and Cadwell is
here she is co-founder she's the CEO of
the good trade comm thank you for
joining us today man well our first
question today is from Erica in well
here Los Angeles California I'm
wondering if you have a thought about
minimalist hygiene because I am just
exhausted trying to keep up with
everything you're supposed to do to be a
woman a modern woman with you know color
and cuts and waxing and tweezing and
shaving and showering and drying her
hair you know how can I be a minimalist
without being gross you know just what
wait where is the line when it comes to
hygiene Ryan can you explain to Erica
how can she can live as a modern woman
yes mansplain oh my god here's the thing
I'll tell you waxing that makes me
anxious just the thought of laughs yeah
right so so I get my unibrow waxed
sometimes do you and it hurts really bad
really what Amy your your website the
good trade com you you actually and
other contributors write about a lot a
lot of I mean there's a whole lot to
unpack in Erica's question here she
heads the sort of shotgun of it was
health care or beauty care or
it was it went from waxing to all of a
sudden showering and blow drying hair
and I get it it becomes
anxiety-producing can we talk a little
bit about this first of all I relate a
lot I think there's so many messages and
so much pressure for women about
everything we have to do to prove that
we're taking care of ourselves and I
think so many times that comes with like
we need to buy more things we need we
need the cleanser then we need the face
wash to remove the cleanser and then you
know there's just like this this
expectation that I think is really
unfair to our actual well-being but I
think there are a few ways to kind of
think differently about it one is to
think about the products that are
actually meaningful for you or the
routines taking a shower makes the list
for me yeah and there are those
essentials that I think we all need to
feel good about how we present ourselves
but then once you know those essentials
looking for products that have really
minimal ingredients so looking for
really clean minimal ingredients helps
you be safer and the products you're
using but then have a lower impact on
the environment as well you know it's
and then also figuring I think the
appropriate amount like I agree I'm I'm
in the shower camp with you like I I
think it's a four take a shower I don't
think it's important to take a shower
ten times a day right and so that what
is the appropriate amount and then I
think obviously that's a that is a
parodic exaggeration of of course I'm
not gonna take ten ten showers a day but
then what's the appropriate amount of
products that are going to add value to
your life because as you just said we
feel compelled to have not just the
cleanser but the scrub and everything
else because we're marketed to in ways
to say you have to have this and so if
I'm talking to someone like Erica that I
guess the question I'm gonna ultimately
ask her is what's appropriate for your
life and then then what can you what can
you do without for a temporary period of
time to see what is actually appropriate
for you yeah and then I think another
question I'd have asked her is maybe
whatever the things she uses that she
could find like a Silver Bullet product
that might have many multi uses so for
me that might be coconut oil it's a
great makeup remover it's a great
moisturizer body lotion it's great after
Sun care if you have a sunburn it's
antibacterial I'm using it to treat my
puppies ear infection is great like you
know finding those products that you can
use across many different uses limits
the number of products that you feel you
have to buy and consume yes I started
washing my face with water
recently it's Listerine no man I was
using like this lab actually you were
there when she sold it to me in Chicago
like like years and years ago when we in
the corporate world we'd took a trip out
of Chicago we were a Bloomingdale's and
like like we were walking on you know
the the mirror or magic mile miracle
mile the shopping mile miracle mile and
like I felt you know not even not even
one but like we walk into Bloomingdale's
I'm like I'm in Chicago in the miracle
mile and I'm you know like I felt all
hoity-toity and I remember we walked
into a polo store and I saw this like
$15,000 blazer and of course like I
would never but remember that I looked I
looked at Josh and I was like should I
do it but anyway no it's it is it is
interesting like how we sell ourselves
when I was sold on like this face wash I
was using it for years and years and
years and then my skin was not doing
well and my wife Mariah she was like you
know I heard like washing your face with
water is actually the best thing to wash
it yeah so that's what I've been doing
it's been working on great but I'd say
the one thing that stands out with
Erica's question with me is these things
that she feels like she's supposed to do
so whenever I get that feeling if I'm
supposed to do something I've got to ask
myself and as a minimalist I would ask
myself Who am I doing this for like am i
doing it for myself oh my am i doing it
for someone else like Mariah
I don't ever you know suggest to her the
way that she needs to keep herself I
mean she ultimately does things for
herself that makes her feel beautiful
and that makes her you know feel like
and you know at modern
woman but men it is like going on
Instagram it is like I don't know
advertisement city with all the eyeliner
you're supposed to have and the face
wash you're supposed to have and thank
God she doesn't get caught up in that
but Erica ask yourself who are you doing
it for if you're doing it for someone
else or if you're doing it because you
know an advertisement told you you're
supposed to do it
that is certainly that's your that's
gonna be an endless an endless pursuit
you're right where you're gonna have a
bunch of people dragging you in
different directions then right like you
you this person say you're supposed to
do this the next person you're supposed
to do this and they're pulling you in a
million different directions and all of
a sudden you're you're fulfilling
everyone else's standard of what beauty
is as opposed to figuring out what is
appropriate for you there's this really
unfortunate trend very like wellness in
self care is being overlapped with the
amount of products you're supposed to
have to sustain that kind of lifestyle
and unfortunately that's not the root of
what will heal our traumas or help our
anxieties and in fact I think they make
us more anxious when we try these
products and they don't bring us the
value in the hope in that maybe
self-confidence out that we're looking
for and so it's this very like negative
self-defeating cycle and I think
especially for women there are all these
retrograde notions around beauty and
what a woman's worth is is based on how
much she's spending on these you know
micro needling treatments or you know
and I don't have a problem against any
of those things some of those things
make me feel amazing but it's exactly
that question what makes me feel good
fits in my lifestyle and who is it for
yeah we're trying to do here is often I
think all of us get caught up is we're
trying to by shortcuts write it and so
if I just spend this fifty dollars is
hundred dollars on this product or
service all of a sudden I'm going to get
some magic result remember back in like
the the 80s and 90s they had these
infomercials where like they probably
still do it somewhere now there's the
equivalent where you put these like
electrodes on your abs and all of a
sudden it worked your abs for you yeah
yeah you were all of a sudden good at
six pack abs you'd have to do anything
but sit on your couch watch TV and get
ripped wouldn't that be nice right it
doesn't
yeah I just been you know the 39.99 on
these electrodes and all of a sudden
might know it doesn't work like that
there's there's work required and then
some of these things these products or
services can augment that experience you
ever buy your way to well-being but you
but you can buy some tools that will
help you in in that journey toward
well-being
Podcast shine you got a tweet that you
can not buy your way to well-being that
is really really good well the other
thing to it like for Erica let's say
she's I don't know if she's single or
not but let's say she is single and
she's doing all these things because
she's trying to like it attract a mate
like I would anyone out there doing that
I would ask like are these sustainable
habits because once you find the mate
like are there certain things that oh
now I have a mate I don't have to do
this anymore like wouldn't it be much
better to like just be yourself attract
the type of person that to accept you
for who you are and not this you know
fabricated version of oneself yeah I
think the last thing I'll say to Erica
is you need to understand what your
values are so you can understand your
needs otherwise everyone else's needs
are going to become your needs even
though they're probably not even your
once let alone your needs so Erica I'm
going to send you a copy of our book
minimalism it talks about the five
foundational values that Ryan and I
often talk about and how you can
discover what is appropriate for you and
so if you like our podcast you'll like
the audiobook version of minimalism live
a meaningful life or if you want the
book book or the eBook version we'll be
happy to send those to you as well Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
indeed we do so so Amy and this is how
it works we're at the minimalists on all
the social media networks you're at the
good trade on on social media and so
people will tweet us questions they
Instagram with questions that DM us
questions and we try to answer them with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal Maxim's in the show notes
we're also going to put links to all the
Articles that we talked about today with
the good trade as well they're in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
pithy answers all of our minimal Maxim's
in one place thanks to our good friend
Jessica :
Williams minimal Maxim's calm here's
what we actually do though we just
ramble on a bit until we find something
beautiful yeah and the Jessica does a
good job of sharing on social media
she's actually the person who exposed us
to you so Thank You Jessica for for
exposing us to the good trade what I
love about Jess and Sean is like they'll
fix my grammar when I totally you know
screw up and short pithy answer like
sometimes I'll see something on Twitter
with someone's quote me I'm like did I
actually say that like that's good it's
all thanks to Sean and Jess our first
question is from Olivia what are some
easy non overwhelming ways to introduce
sustainability practices into a
relationship without it coming across as
judgmental
I would love if my fiancee was just as
jazzed about sustainability as I am but
I don't want to overstep with all my
sustainable quirks well so I have a
pithy answer and I'd love to hear what a
man has to think about it so so the
thing that stood out to me and Olivia's
question here is what are some easy non
overwhelming ways and that word easy
that's the shortcut thing we were just
talking about right so my fifth the
answer is important changes aren't easy
but they can be simple and I think too
often we conflate the two right we're
looking for the the path of least
resistance what is easy but but simple
is the opposite simple as well-curated
it's difficult work but it is the most
direct path toward whatever change we're
trying to make so Olivia is asking well
look my husband is just not jazzed about
sustainability and and an uncharitable
reading of this question would say how
do I force my husband to be more
sustainable I'm sure you get questions
like this all the time yeah I think it
starts with education and and actually
getting buy-in together so start with
documentaries start with a couple of
books I can usually get my husband to
sit down for a documentary with me on
some topic you know if I'm interested in
it he'll give an hour to watch something
or an hour and a half so podcasts
documentaries I think are a great place
to start to lay the foundation because
it's very
difficult to get a partner on board with
behavior changes until they kind of
adopt the same value so there's that
direction and then I think the other is
just live sustainably yourself you know
implement things that that are working
for you and I've learned so much for my
husband who you know in so many
different ways and he's learned for me
in the years that we've been together in
different passion areas but they overlap
and then come together so educate
yourselves together and then lead by
example I think the beautiful part about
leading by example is also showing your
significant other the the benefits
through that right because when we talk
about minimalism people I can overwhelm
and I think about like just cleaning out
their closet or their junk drawers or
just how am I going to declutter my
entire house
that's so overwhelming people like why
would I even want to do that but that's
the important thing why would you want
to do that what are the benefits of
living more sustainably so Olivia
instead of just telling your your
husband like here's what I'm doing you
should do it to talk about why you're
doing that and what benefits you're
experiencing and then also one of the
benefits he's gonna experience because
they might even be different from the
benefits that you experience yeah my pet
the answer is pretty simple it's the
only thing people dislike more than
change is being changed so Olivia you're
not going to like force your husband
into being more sustainable I know with
Mariah and I like when we first got
together I thought I was pretty
I don't know conscious about the
environment and like living with her
over time I have really realized like oh
wow there are things I haven't
considered like something small but as
like if you get q-tips you know don't
get the plastic q-tips like just
something really small like that or
ziploc bags I really did sound like I
went through a ton of them and because I
didn't go through a ton of them I never
really thought about using ziplock bags
but like mariah has shown me like no
like not only can you use few ziplock
bags but you can use fewer by reusing
them washing them out things like that
so that I guess ultimately you know I
want to have a good relationship and
part of having a good relationship is
going out of your way to support each
other so with Mariah she supports me
with educating me on what's better for
the environment and because I want to
support her I and I want to you know be
environmentally friendly I will go out
of my way to kind of I don't know pick
up on some of her habits but that's
exactly what it is it's me picking up on
her habits yeah I think that the other
thing we need to keep in mind is shame
almost never works it's and it never
works long-term right you can you can
shame someone to changing a behavior
immediately I think back to when Ryan
and I were in the corporate world we had
a boss who which is a tyrant he would
shame people for not working 80 hours a
week and or taking your all of your
vacation days in in one year yeah I
remember like the weird passive
aggressiveness of like you we took I'm
gonna take an extra vacation day this
this week must be nice and you're like
it's gross right it was a toxic
environment you got he got fired
eventually anyway so don't create that
toxic environment where you are that if
you want someone to follow you you don't
drag them in your direction
you you want to show them why they would
follow you in that direction as mariah
did with Ryan
you're much more likely to follow her
towards sustainability because she's
showing you the benefit she's showing
you the good side of as opposed to can't
believe you Ryan yeah what a piece of
crap you are really gentle and she has
definitely taught me a lot all right our
next question is from Tabitha what would
you consider a good place to start for
someone who is looking to live a more
sustainable life rethink what's so I
think what's compelling about the site
is you take approach to products who you
Ryan and I are aggressively minimal with
a lot of the stuff that we talked about
we rarely talk about products but you do
so you shed a light on various products
not in the way or set you're saying you
should consume this this is gonna make
you better but like let's highlight some
things that some people get value from
so if you want to start living more
sustainably as Tabitha's asking here
yeah I think it's definitely a good
place to start but how what's a good
place in her life to start maybe it's a
better question that's a great question
well I think once you kind of have an
inclination towards minimalism you're
already
far down the path in terms of thinking
about the things that you bring into
your home and into your life and making
sure they're a value to you so that's a
really natural place to start but then
thinking about just the different
categories of your lifestyles or your
transportation your food food and
clothing how are these things that you
can make little changes in your life to
be more environmentally conscious and
sustainable so is that public
transportation like we were talking
about earlier is that riding a bike is
that for food eating locally is so is
such a benefit in terms of the
environmental ecosystem so there are
really actually very easily implemented
behavior changes in each different
categories but I think it is helpful to
have a book a website or resource a
community that's kind of helping you
think about those different areas of
your life and what makes sense for you
yeah in psychology the term is is
chunking and I like this because when
you memorize a phone number which we
rarely do these days now
but it's impossible not impossible
obviously to just take a ten digit
number it's much more difficult to
remember and so instead we have this
area code 937 like okay I know that
state in Ohio right and and then we have
the prefix and like you're memorizing it
in chunks and it makes it more palatable
and I think the same thing is true when
we're looking at making a change in our
life like where are the areas the
categories that you say that I want to
change and I can start looking at one
particular area I could say okay maybe
it's about fashion right now I want want
to be more sustainably minded when when
when I'm approaching fashion or maybe
it's its food maybe it is mad I'm just
driving way way too much and and we want
to figure out how can I be more
sustainable as opposed to trying to
change everything at once look at one
category and find that I have a pithy
answer here for you Ryan
the direction is more important than the
goal and I think that too often we're
like I want to live a zero-waste
lifestyle or whatever and yeah and so
while there are maybe the direction
still living zero
wastes lifestyles hey I want to be more
sustainable and you can eventually
decrease the waste that I put out right
and you can start to quantify that and
smaller leaps as opposed to well I'm
failing if I if I produce any waste
whatsoever I'm failing no maybe you
reframe that and I'm succeeding if I
reduce my footprint however you want to
measure that by 10 percent this year
yeah yeah it's like I don't want to I
don't want to offend anymore zero wet
zero waste listeners because like
sometimes we'll say something and like
they will DM me or something they're all
upset but I just you know to your point
of it's impossible when when when I
think of zero waste being impossible I
think about like when I go get a cup of
coffee like I could absolutely bring my
own to-go cup and go to the coffee store
and get some coffee pour it in there and
screw on the lid go about my day and
drink it go home and wash it and I have
not produced any waste that day however
the the waste that goes into making that
cup of coffee like yeah maybe it's not
on me but it's still on the coffee shop
so that's that's is that kind of when
you think it's impossible is that what
you kind of think about in order to
exist in society there is some level of
waste generated by the way that we're
interacting you know in the world as it
is today and I think that's okay I don't
think that we should allow shame and
guilt to take you know to stop us from
taking the next step from wherever we
are and that might be very incremental
but it's progress it's movement and I
think that's the responsibility that
each of us have I totally agree
my pithy answer for Josh is this small
inconsistent actions will add up to big
changes so when I was doing a little
research on the environment like what
are the biggest things that are hurting
the environment right now and by far
airplanes is if we could yes if we could
stop flying we would cut out so much co2
there's not a good substitute though for
airplane travel so I guess like I'm
gonna kind of put you on the spot here
with with the average you know first
world citizen what is typically like the
biggest waste factor in in a home do you
have any idea what that would be well
certainly it's plane travel I mean you
could eat
the next one would be a red meat oh okay
yeah how interesting so red meat but
then also your your this will change
depending on the size of your home and
and what you're using but energy
consumption in the home is a huge
environmental impact as well so and
there are ways to reduce all these
things something for me I do a lot of
plane travel and so I have thought about
how can I think about my diet
differently because that's something
that is a little bit easier for me to
control and substitute exactly like I
still travel home to see my family I
travel home for or I travel for work
frequently and so I think looking at the
areas but in terms of big impact
it's definitely transportation so air
travel and cars food and red meat is
another big area and then household
consumption and water electricity I love
it so Tabitha I mean you don't have to
do all those things at once she doesn't
have to like write this list and then
tomorrow start making an impact with all
those things but choose something
whether it's eating a little bit less
red meat or whether it is taking public
transportation make these small little
incremental changes and they do add up
to a lot if I were to just a pin that a
little bit I would say also the small
incremental in actions they also lead to
big changes in the negative direction
right I think about the amount of
plastic bottles I used to use that's
just one more bottle right like what's
what's the big deal but then all of a
sudden it's like if I'm doing six
plastic bottles today like I just do the
math on that really quick that's a
billion bottles a year Ryan if you're
rounding to the nearest billion just
fact check us on that one podcast shot
now looks like we have several more
surprise questions this week let's see
what what was your minimalist journey
inspired by environmental concerns what
are your recommendations regarding
minimalist furniture we've got our
article to talk about here from Amiens
website also what point at what point do
you consider an item no longer
repairable and simply replace it how do
I become more intentional as a shopper
also the 10 best affordable brands for
ethical fashion on a budget and nine
apps to help you live more sustainably
and
I want to play another game of overrated
or underrated I always lose like I'm
gonna talk about coffee we're talk about
sandwiches
avocados sandwiches underrated I'll tell
you right now well we will get into that
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you currently listen to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode over on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about a
bunch of stuff that we don't usually
talk about in public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it a hundred
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than 100 private
podcast episodes you can find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional private podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week Josh being informed is more
important than ever these days so I want
to encourage you to read more and get
informed and by the way I got some
voicemail tips and comments from our
listeners check him out hi this is Tara
calling from Chicago I just listened to
episode 12 on money and wanted to share
some advice that helps me in my
minimalist lifestyle during and after
college my dad advised that I didn't
attend a university where the tuition
would cost more than what I would make
in my first year entry salary with that
degree after following that advice I
picked up a second job after graduation
to pay off my loans and I continued to
live with roommates to keep costs low
between both of those approaches I paid
off over twenty thousand dollars in debt
in less than a year the financial
freedom has opened up more doors than I
could ever imagine so I was able to quit
my second job afford to buy a new car
travel the country and move to my dream
city to pursue my life's passion all
within five years of time it was a long
and difficult road working 70 plus hours
a week for a year but it was all
short-term pain for long-term gain and
worked every initial
sacrifice to get me to where I am today
stay there my name is Sam McGee I'm from
Spokane Washington and I wanted to
respond to the episode on creativity
with Mattie availa I love the ideas that
are expressed in this episode which I do
feel are consistently hit upon in every
short documentary to map us out every
week I have been a longtime follower as
a documentary filmmaker myself I've
spent the last year replacing urge to
consume with the habit of creating this
is one of the topics you discussed in
this episode I found in my commercial
work and in my personal life it's become
a lifestyle of creating photographing my
family creating films about my kids for
the purpose of sharing that art with my
family for the purpose of groups therapy
with my wife as we learn to be the best
parents possible for my kids that's the
that's the point that I want to make
still making creating for me is a form
of therapy it's a powerful way for me to
process the world and invite others to
join me in that conversation invite
others to engage and consider these
moments in their own lives I'm thankful
for that invitation that you put out
there on the internet every day with the
minimalist quote content as well as
Matt's content I do personally need the
consistency I choose to listen for the
tenth time because I need to be reminded
to kill the habit of constantly
consuming alright y'all thanks again to
Amy and for joining us today make sure
you check out her website the good trade
comm they also have a newsletter over
there a daily newsletter and you can
find them on social media at the good
trade on all the networks and real quick
four right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists Ryan
we're going on tour we're going to
Canada
[Laughter]
international tour we're actually not
going on tour I take that back it's just
you know many hopes you just got up how
many people were so excited
well I've good news though so for the
people who are really excited yes
so you and I have been on nine different
tours in the last eight years okay
and many of those stops we recorded
either audio or video for and you can
find our previous tour stops now all in
one place if you go to the minimalists
comm slash previous I moved one over I
think over 200 tour stops almost
certainly over all way over - it feels
like a million tour stops I'm running to
the nearest million and you can find all
of them there some of them have links to
video or audio and if you are a patreon
true fan on patreon you will have access
to all of our future events as well
we're recording all of our future events
so we are certainly going to be doing
some stuff we got a a book we're working
on we have our second film that we're
working on I'm sure we'll do some tour
stops in the future if you're on our
email list you'll be the first to know
about those but if you want to if you
want the experience of of us then it's
all there the minimalists com a slash
previous to find all of our previous
tour stops and you can find and listen
to all of our future events as a true
fan on patreon if you have a comment
question or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us voicemail four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists com am I allowed to call in
and leave messages yes I've already
heard some of them always a butt-dial
yeah you can comment on this episode
youtube.com slash the minimalist you're
not allowed to comment though right and
if you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at the
minimalists comm you can also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week
whenever you sign up for our email list
for our added value segment this week
let's listen to the title track from our
good friend Paul a Canyon City killing
it yeah Canyon city's new album is
called Bluebird and I think that Paul's
music always just sounds to me like a
calm walk home
and I hope you enjoy this title track it
is called Bluebird from Canyon City and
if you leave here today with just one
message folks we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus